ومع استمرار المواجهات وترد الاوضاع
الامنيه في السودان وسط استمراري عمليات
الاجلاء تستمر حركه النزوح الداخليه الى
مناطق بعيده عن مواقع الاشتباكات او الى
دول الجوار حيث يستمر الابلاغ عن نزوح
المدنيين في ولايات الخرطوم والولايه
الشماليه والنيل الازرق وشمال كردفان
وشمال دارفور وغرب دارفور وجنوب دارفور
الى جانب التحركات عبر الحدود الى الدول
المجاوره وقد حذرت الامم المتحده من ان
ربع مليون سوداني قد يكونون في طريقهم
للهرب برا الى الدول المجاوره ومن بين
الدول المجاور للسودان فان اهم التحركات
وفق مفوضيه اللاجئين هي نحو تشاد وجنوب
السودان
المفوضيه اوضحت ان الذين شقوا طريقهم
بانفسهم الى المناطق الحدوديه مع تشاد
يقدر عددهم بنحو 20 الفا كما انها تتوقع
عبور نحو 45 الف لاجئ سوداني جديد الى
جنوب السودان والى مصر الجاره الشماليه ذا
فقد ذكرت المفوضيه ان لديها تقارير عن بدء
خروج بعض النازحين الى مصر في حين اعلنت
السلطات المصريه ان الاف الاشخاص من مختلف
الجنسيات تمكنوا من الخروج من السودان الى
مصر عبر معبري قسطل وارجين حيث يتجاوز
عددهم العشره الاف شخص لمتابعه المزيد
الاخبار والبرامج والقصص الانسانيه
والوثائقيات والتقارير الاخباريه لا تنسوا
الاشتراك في قناتنا على اليوتيوب الضغط
على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات